c'est une étude parue dans libération
inégalités êtes-vous riche si vous
gagnez plus de 3600 73 euros net par
mois vous pouvez considérer que oui tout
certaines oreilles je peux en parler
on l'observatoire des inégalités c'est
richard et environ 4 5 millions en
france soit 7 % de la population des
riches ce sont des cadres des
professions libérales et puis des hauts
fonctionnaires par exemple un seuil de
richesse calculée par rapport aux nues
mensuels nets du milieu de la société
qui ne met pourtant pas tout le monde
d'accord alors les personnes au dessus
de 3700 73 euros sont henrich solon
merci rigoler rigoler
rigole
alors ils filent vers l'est alors
j'étais sur ceux qui ont mis non j'étais
sûr que c'était lié aux gens ton et
j'en étais sûr on va les laisser
s'exprimer d'abord et benjamin castaldi
va nous sortir fou sa fameuse phrase un
camp d'habitude compter dans le coup tu
es dans le
trou oui moi j'aime pas ce chiffre parce
qu'il vise à culpabiliser les gens les
gens qui viennent 3673 euros par mois
déjà estimé vous regagnez de ça parce
que vous êtes riche même si 93 pour cent
de la population gagne moins que ça je
suis désolé on n'est pas riche quand on
à 3673 euros par mois être riche cette
fortune et sait mettre énormément
d'argent de côté ses cuisines d'ayem
plusieurs bien c'est pouvoir aller au
restaurant quand on veut c'est voyager
quand on veut et je suis désolé quand on
gagne cette somme là par mois qu'on paye
un loyer qu'on a des charges et qu'on a
un train de vie normal justement on a un
train de vie normal et on ne peut pas se
permettre de vivre de manière superflu
donc non on n'est pas pauvre évidemment
mais on n'est pas riche avec cette somme
là par moise et hypocrite de dire ce
qu'ils te pose problème c'est juste le
mot rishmawi mais ces messieurs les
joueurs qui n'ont pas de vivre voilà
c'est des gens qui n'ont pas de prouver
ma courbe et de maîtrise est
considéré comme riche non mais pas les
sacs de riz c'est ce seul qui voudrait
dire que seulement 7 pour ea semble un
peu la face très riche
ça donc oui vous vouliez dire non
monsieur mais bien sûr bien sûr qu'on
est riche c'est mais benjamin ces deux
fois le smic donc vous êtes riche mais
les gens qui font bien sûr que je suis
riche et et même nous on fait partie des
gens encore plus riches parce que ça
c'est un seul médian mais en dessous de
ça les gens qui ont le smic eux ils
souffrent le smic a atteint vous êtes
pauvre vous avez du mal à vous nourrir
le problème c'est l'alimentation et avec
cette somme là 3673 ou à deux 7700 avez
vous nourrir 7700 c'est énorme
avec de série avec deux ans
après impôts voilà eh bien ces deux
barèmes là je suis désolé vous êtes
piges oui mais oui il ya 12 est riche
mais aucun problème voilà pour quoi
faire oui y'a pas tout le monde qui a
deux il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont deux
enfants et qui sont seuls et qu'ils
gagnent la somme aussi donc on peut pas
donc bien sûr série revient sur 1000
euros pour tout le monde c'est pas 7000
euros pour tout le monde c'est aussi la
marianne est en couple avec deux
employés hier beaucoup de gens qui sont
seules avec des enfants aussi falloir
mieux nourrir mais après ma fille
remonté comme un coucou non mais moi non
plus entre la globalisation c'est à dire
que ça dépend d'abord où on vit mais que
cela dépend quel âge on a alors moi ma
grand mère elle touche beaucoup moins
cet argent mais elle estime que
finalement bas elle a une toute petite
retraite mais là pas besoin de beaucoup
plus elle s'estime pas riche mais voilà
il peut manger à sa faim on peut l'aider
tout ça donc en fait je trouve que de
globaliser comme ça ça donne une fausse
idée de ce que c'est parce que c'est pas
pareil de gagner cet argent là à paris
quand on vit dans le cantal en voilà on
n'a pas les mêmes c'est pas les mêmes
c'est pas le même coût voilà donc ça
c'est ça qui me gêne et ensuite il ya
deux choses ya les revenus donc ces 313
euros il ya aussi le patrimoine et
patrimoine riche ses 490 mille euros à
partir de 490 mille euros de patrimoine
on est considéré comme riche et ensuite
à une deuxième chose tawhidi moi je
gagne 1500 euros par mois mais j'ai avec
quelqu'un comme pinault arnault hanouna
à ce moment là est ce que je suis riche
parce que je suis paris
t
[Applaudissements]
inquiétez pas les sorties d'elle-même
mais
c'est la relativité c'est à dire
effectivement par rapport à vous c'est
bon mais par rapport à des gens qui je
le 10 du mois si je lui ai alors dit moi
maintenant et ça c'est on est restée
makkasan relativité alors pourquoi mais
paraît que cela m'a évidemment c'est
évidemment que par rapport à tout ce qui
est 1500 hommes et 400 euros par mois
oui effectivement c'est beaucoup
d'argent mais c'est pas ça et riche
démonte un sens et ris facebook comme le
dit guillaume c'est pas avoir 3100 euros
par mois c'est pas vrai tu fais rien de
plus que ne le sait mais non mais tu
manges tu as pas de problème pour vivre
et pour te nourrir ou ces bayonnais est
riche alors mesdames et mesdames
messieurs ne sais pas
je ne sais pas c'est pas parmi les
anciens sur les réseaux qui disent on
vit très très bien on vit très
suivie vivien tu lis bien la crise pour
mousser oui on érige et belle somme cs
mais c'est subjectif certes jamais sa
conférence je suis à paris là j'avais
pas le paramètre à 2 parce que si vous
êtes de
saveur à dire des fois tu peux pas être
2 des foyers n'a acquis que cette somme
et l'otan mais toi cerexhe de vie est ce
qu'on hérite mois moi je dis qu'on est
très très très très très aisée et
d'abord la courbe elle parle 7% de la
population c'est deux fois et demie
d'avoir trois fois le smic parfois le
smi est quelqu'un qui touchent le smic
par rapport à quelqu'un qui va toucher
300 au mois d'avril il a touché la
personne qui va toucher ce mais il a
fait l'année du smic c'est à dire qu'il
a fait de 14000 euros à l'année pour un
smic et lui va faire 44 mille euros donc
il est super bien aisé on peut pas dire
qu'il soit malheureux on a un seuil de
pauvreté qui à 1100 euros certes il ya
des gens sur toute une année qui vont
toucher 13000 euros s'ils travaillent
cela on n'est donc pas à 7% de la
population et coutumes et donc les 10%
les plus riches sont les 7 7% c3513
après vous avez les 5% les plus riches
ceux qui sont au dessus de la boîte 1156
les 1% les plus riches au dessus de 7680
et les 0,1 pour cent du pays ceux qui
sont tués je peux vous dire que c'est
pas la même vie parce que moi j'ai eu
des salaires ags je tape les salaires à
2000 euros et là j'ai des salaires à
prendre mais c'est pas la même vie
rangée une ferme ici ça c'est pas la
même mais quand tu vas au restaurant
comme que tu veux tu arrêtes de regarder
les formules point la formule à 10
balles et vers la raison tu prendras
dernière un tiramisu mon fils c'est pas
du tout la bnci mais quand tu vendeur
que tu charges ton caddie sans calculer
exactement pas du même avis quand on dit
que d'essence est là nous aurons j
-louis c'est chiant naissance à la 2
euros bordel de merde je pense aux
autres mais moi je suis pas impacter
parce que je suis maintenant dans cette
catégorie des vacances quand tu les
réserves avant tu prenais un mobile home
et tu faisais delà des pâtes et du
jambon maintenant j'essaye de prendre un
truc tout compris ils crient c'est pas
du tout la même dit il j'ai des amis ou
bien vous dire que quand tu prends 45000
euros dans une année c'est pas quatorze
mille euros c'est pas le smic à celle là
tu es dans l'élite 7% pour moi tu fais
partie de l'élite et par riesch était
très très aisé valais on le dit 3006
après impôts ça veut dire qu'il a touché
4100 4002 et s'il a des enfants il a
même enlevé peut-être ses enfants sur
ses impôts donc c'est à dire qu'ils
veulent il a touché encore même plus
puisqu'il a enlevé ses enfants donc ça
pour moi je dis que tu es
désormais maîtrisée w dérange moi ce qui
me dérange dans ses dents dans ces
trafics bourse là c'est qu'il y a des
limites y est pour moi pas là je me dis
moi pour moi inchangé signons ces néo il
doit être dans les sept pour cent à
une infirmière et bien sur un île
influents d'iran et firmi célèbre guinée
beaucoup plus des gens qui se moquent
qui s'occupe de personnes en difficulté
ils doivent gagner beaucoup plus je
trouve qu en fait voilà le problème qui
a il ya des gens aussi tourné travail
est il est vrai un travail à pénibilité
énorme et qui gagnent voilà le smic
alors qu'il devrait gagner bon dieu
c'est vrai qu'il ya il céder ces
disparités la voix la banalisation des
salaires des saignées quorum de corps
certainement s'il va directement
l'allemagne est passée les nombreux mois
c'est ça quand vous avez quand vous avez
un couple enseignants et infirmières
sont à deux ont ils ont deux ou trois
enfants et qui disent ils n'arrivent pas
à s'en sortir c'est inadmissible
d'enseignants cheryl un couple
d'enseignants s'ils n'arrivent pas à
s'en sortir avec 2000 euros net et 2000
euros de ca fait 4000 euros avec deux
mois de vacances et les avantages qu'ils
ont j'ai rien contre les enseignants
son rapport aux infirmiers j'ai rien
contre les enseignants il fait un boulot
formidable ils font un boulot formidable
je parle pas des gens qui sont à celles
qui sont un animateur je parle des
enseignants ils font un boulot
formidable parce qu'ils éduquent nos
enfants et je veux tu dois payer plus et
le vrai scandale c'est laisser les
arméniens
je vois des agriculteurs retraités mais
que feront les agresseurs aient tous les
matins
il vous reste 300 euros quand on voit
bien sur
ses impôts à payer des joueurs préfèrent
gattaz le vrai qu'il est pendu vient de
convaincre ayant l'oreille à des
agriculteurs qui sont visés registre ide
ans a eu avec la tempête qui a eu soin
et bien sûr à se faire du bien si je
vous dis moi des agriculteurs il ya une
urgence incroyable sur les agriculteurs
je l'avais on l'avait roady et on va
essayer de devra le faire encore
official l'hôpital non mais les
chauffeurs d'ivoire touche plus qu'une
infirmière réveillez-vous l'infirmière a
fait d'aider des amplitudes de malades
commence à 5 heures du matin a fini à 2
heures du matin à travailler puis dire
que le chauffeur livreur de gagner
mais on dit qu'à un moment donné il ya
des métiers qui doivent valoriser et
surtout on a toujours été au-dessus on
prend toujours les exemples ailleurs
regardez en allemagne en italie les
allemands augmenter leurs semis qui sont
passés devant nous donc il serait
peut-être temps de se rêver avec le smic
par rapport au coût des loyers là vous
avez eu droit il est démago ça y est il
a sorti son drapeau mais les loyers
c'est n'importe quoi en france
penchez-vous sur les loyers c'est une
dinguerie les loyers en fait n'importe
quoi qu'on les règle les bonnes
questions on est dans un pays où les
gens ne sont pas assez payés où ils
payent trop d'impôts et justement
pourquoi ce genre de chiffres sortent
pour culpabiliser les gens pour leur
dire voilà tu viennes déjà 2000 2500
euros mais tu vois tu es presque riches
c'est honteux mais je suis désolée la
réalité c'est qu'avec cette somme n'a on
n'est pas riche quelqu'un qui vit dans
une grande ville ou à paris qui payent
des loyers une fortune avec le coût de
la vie de cet art il va lui restait
moins de 100 euros ou 50 euros ou un
suivi la guerre c'est déjà très bien il
a cappella vivre c'est un choix
les gens qui vont un jour qui menace
apparaît que je monte
mes volets d'une dernier à paris vous
prenez 3006 guillaume et vous mettez des
jaunes il me
faut viser vous mettez de loyer à 2002
2003 par 40 mètres carrés pour voir la
toile et n'avait pas prêt mais en
fait m
[Applaudissements]
mais
les magic
autour de lui plus que ça par mois et je
pense que tout le monde se considère pas
riche autour de la table donc arrêter la
démagogie c'est considérer
mais qui est propriétaire pour notre
esprit est alors qui est propriétaire
c'est normal c'est me faire office
d olivier
richesse et il n'aurait jamais mes
terres
moi je suis propriétaire bien sûr
aménagé encore heureux que j'ai réussi à
lâcher quelques jours bien c'est bien
c'est vrai j'ai bien aimé ce la diva
l'étude est intéressante en revanche
c'est vrai que c'est le patrimoine tête
importants dont on parle de revenus
c'est un peu ridicule
évidemment 3600 c'est énorme c'est un
riche ah oui c'est le patrimoine qui
fait la fortune le patrimoine wallon
comment tu la fais ton patrimoine tu
l'as fait avec le temps et un moment
donné tu vas payer l'impôt sur la
fortune donc y'a un moment donné tu le
fais tu
la fais tu la fais ton patrimoine non
mais parce que globalement dans l'étude
ils disent que si tu as du patrimoine
c'est parce que ton a hérité passé
difficile avec salaire là
allez vous parlerai demain de
savoir ce qu'on pense était spectateur
ça ça m'intéresse ça va oui à 48 points
il sert 651 c'est vraiment moi c'est
très très ses parts à 10